翻訳: Syunsuke Yoshikawa
校正: Yuri Ueda
モノには 名前があります
もちろん 一人一人にも
私たち一人一人にも 名前があります
私は 自分に名前があるということを
当然だと思ってましたので
あまり気にも留めないで
ずっと（生きて）きてしまいましたが
皆さんはいかがですか
ある「聞こえ」に障がいがある人が
「自分は 聾学校に入った６歳の時に
そこで始めて
モノには名前というものがあったんだ
ましてや自分に名前があった
ということを知って とても驚いた」
と言っていました
名前があるから
自分と他人というのを認識できます
そして 自分の名前を呼ばれていると
私が だんだん私らしくなっていきます
そして 自分を大切にするように
なっていくのでは ないでしょうか
そして 聴覚障がい者―
聞こえない人たち というのは―
聞こえないという障がいというのは
ただ聞こえないだけ というにふうに
思われがちなのですけども
実はそれって ちょっと違うかもしれません
赤ちゃんはお腹にいる時から
もういろんな音が聞こえているそうです
羊水の動く音
お母さんの心臓の音
お母さんの声を聴きながら
大きくなっていきます
お母さんの呼び掛けに対して
赤ちゃんは 笑ったり
声を出したり
体を動かしたりします
お母さんと赤ちゃんというのは
意味のある言葉で
コミュニケーションしている
わけではありません
でも この「聞こえ」ということを
切り離して考えることは
できないと思います
そして １歳半ぐらいになると
名前を呼ばれると
「はい」と
返事をするようになります
もう自分が誰ということが
分かっているからです
目や耳から入るいろいろな情報
これは 私たちの知識を 広げてくれます
知識が広がると
いろいろなものを選択したり
判断する力になります
そして それは私たちの心を豊かに
そして 深めるものだと思います
でも 生まれる前から音が入らない
そういう人たちにとって
この社会 どうですか
私が今 話しているような
音声による言語
こういうものを中心として
もう出来上がってしまっています
その社会や生活習慣の中で
聞こえない人たちが
生活するということは
そんなに簡単なことではありません
周りの人からの声掛けが聞こえない
子どもたち
このハンディキャップというのを
どういうように埋めていったら
いいでしょうか
私が聞こえない人たちと
関わるようになったのは
今から30年程前です
実は私の夫は７人兄弟でした
そのうち義兄２人に
「聞こえ」に障がいがありました
ある日 兄弟が集まる食事会に 行ってみると
テーブルが２つ 用意してありました
聞こえる兄弟とその家族
聞こえない兄弟とその家族
というふうに 分かれて座っていたのです
それを見た時
えっ どうして？
どうしてなんだろう？
とても ちょっと不思議な光景でした
聞こえない義兄たちは
聾学校の寮で育ちました
「家に帰ってくるのは年に数回だった」
というふうに聞いています
幼い時 親元を離れて
そういう寮に入らなければいけなかった
兄弟が 別々のテーブルに
座らなければいけない
そういうこと
でも これずっとそうしてきたから
それが当たり前になってました
でも 私から見たら
やっぱり兄弟として家族として
ちょっとやっぱり寂しい気がしました
２つのテーブルを１つにするには
何ができるだろうか
これが私の人生を
本当に大きく変えてしまった出来事でした
もし皆さんの近くに
今聞こえない人がいたら
何をどう思うでしょうか
もしかしたら
「私は手話ができないから」とか
「話が通じないし
よく分からないから 近づけない」と
思ってみえる方も
いるのではないかと思います
実は私がそうでした
義兄たちのことも あったものですから
手話を覚えよう と思って
手話サークルに行きました
そこは結構 賑やかなのですけども
何を話しているのか
全然 分からなかったのです
そして この中の誰が聞こえる人で
誰が聞こえない人なのか
見ただけでは 本当に分からないのです
誰かが近づいてくると
「手話で話しかけられたら どうしよう」
もう怖くて
目を合わせられませんでした
そういう気持ち分かりますか
でもこれ逆に言うと
聞こえない人たちが いつもどこかの場面で
こういう同じ気持ちに
なっているのではないのかなと思います
そして 手話サークルに通って
聞こえない人たちと関わってる間に
簡単なことだったら
手話が少し分からないぐらい
大丈夫ではないのかと
例えば―
書いたりとか
身振りだとか
あれこれとかと 指さしで
何とかこう話ができるのではないのかなと
いうふうに気が付きました
それと 笑顔があれば
もっと理解できて 気持ちが通じるし
分かることも沢山あるのではないのかなと
思います
「聞こえ」に障がいがある男の子の
お母さんのことですが
この子を本当に理解できないことが
いろいろあって
お母さん本当にすごく悩んでいました
学校の帰り道
橋の欄干に石を並べるのです
石をいっぱい並べるのです
そこから そこでずっと立って
日が沈むまで動こうとしません
お母さんは悩んでしまいました
何でこういうことをするのか
何があるのか
それが毎日続きます
もう本当に疲れてきました
でもある時
男の子の様子がちょっと違うのです
同じように石は並んでいるのですけど
石と お日様を こう順番に
こう指さすのです
なんかお母さんに
一生懸命伝えようとしてるのですけど
お母さんは最初 分からなかったのです
でも それを見ていて
「あっ そういうことだったんだ」
気が付きました
男の子は毎日
学校の帰りに ここを通ります
そして毎日
真っ赤な大きな夕日が沈んでいくのを
見ていました
それで―
道を見たら 石が落ちてます
この子（石）に見せてあげたい
一番見えるところに 石を置いてあげた
「どう？見える？」
それだけのことなのです
でもお母さんは それに気が付いて
こんなに一生懸命
私に教えようとしてくれたのに
分からないのは この子ではなかった
私の方だったのだ
その子をギュッと抱きしめて
涙が止まらなかったそうです
この世の中 いろんな人がいます
中には ちょっと理解できないな という
言動の人もいるのも事実です
でも 分からないなと思っているのは
こちらのことで
その人としたら その人なりの
ちゃんとした理由が あるかもしれません
その人を分かろうとする
分かろうとする気持ち
それが いろんなことを 気付かせてくれて
いろんなことが出来るように
なるのではないでしょうか
障がいが「ある」「ない」とかではないのです
やっぱりその人自身―
その人に―
その人の心に やっぱり関心を持つ
人は関心を持たないと 何も見えません
私が 手話を始めて間もない頃
ちょっと手話ができます
嬉しい時です
お義母さんに 聞こえないお義兄さんとの前で
ちょっと言ってしまったのです
「私が通訳してあげるから
何か話して―
何か話してみてよ」 というと
義母は 義兄たちの顔を見ながら
静かにこう言いました
「寂しい思い させたね」
義母は きっとずっとそのことを
心の中で 言い続けてきたんだろうなと
その時 思いました
義母も 義兄たちも きっと
話したい時に 話したいこと というのが
沢山あったと思うのです
でも―
「聞こえないから 言っても分からないし
そんなこと無理」
最初から もう諦めていたのです
持っている言葉が違うと
お互いに 相手に
自分の思いを伝えるということは
本当に難しいことです
でも 私がちょっと声を掛けて
手話を使ったことで
心が伝わったのだと実感しました
そして 心と心がつながる方法というのは
あったのだと思います
私の好きなヘレン・ケラーの言葉に
あなたの持つ ランプの灯りを
いま少し高く かかげてください
人びとが 希望の道を 強く歩めるように
この言葉は
私の活動の道しるべに なっています
私たちの活動の中の一つに
公園の草取りというのがあります
それは聞こえない人と 聞こえる人が
一緒になって
一生懸命 草取りをするのですけども
その後のアイスキャンディを
みんなで かじるのを楽しみに
もう汗だくになって活動しています
それは 聞こえない人が
障がいがあっても自分たちにできること
簡単なことかも しれないですけど
草取りぐらい
でも 自分たちにできることを
それをしながら
社会に参加したい
そして 地域の一員として そこにいたい
社会に役に立って そこにいる
そういう気持ちが あるからだと思います
障がい者になる可能性というのは
誰にでもあります
その時あなたなら
何をしてほしいでしょうか
そのままの自分を
認めてほしいと思いませんか
私にできることは何でしょう
私にできることは
障がいがあるとか ないとかではなくて
やっぱり その人自身に向き合うこと
寄り添うこと―
これはもう寄り添うことしか
できないのですけど
寄り添うこと
そして 何よりその人を大切に思うことでは
ないのかなと 思います
でも あんまり気負ってばかりいては
疲れてしまって 長続きしません
それだと あまり意味がなくなってきます
やっぱり自然体です
あるがままの自然体で
細く長く関わっていくこと
なのではないのかなと
私は思っています
ありがとうございました
(拍手)